en este viernes olímpico a latinoamérica
continuó cosechando medallas en
atletismo primero en los 20 kilómetros
de la marcha olímpica sandra arenas de
colombia consigue la medalla de plata
tras cruzar la línea de meta tan sólo 25
segundos detrás de quien se quedó con el
oro la italiana antonella palmisano en
una hora 29 minutos y 12 segundos on the
china se quedó con la medalla de bronce
y esta noche también se llevó a cabo en
la final de los 400 metros planos y fue
mari lady paulino de república
dominicana quien creó una bonita
sorpresa para su país tras quedarse con
la medalla de plata y la que había hecho
el segundo tiempo más rápido de las
clasificaciones fue el jeannette miller
vivo de bahamas quien se colgó el oro y
allyson felix de eeuu el bronce una vez
más se le escapa el título a la
estadounidense y esta noche de atletismo
se terminó por una sorpresa en el relevo
masculino del 4% con italia que se colgó
la medalla de oro por delante de gran
bretaña
y canadá lo último fue un partido
también el trío que jugaba pues lograr
su medalla de bronce ante japón y bueno
cosa realizada cosa hecha ya que los
mexicanos ganaron este partido 3 goles
por 1